[Music]
so around september i i did a series of
videos where i was solving puzzles on
chess.com in particular rating ranges i
did one on beginner problems
intermediate problems and grandmaster
level problems and the the last one of
these the grand master level puzzles got
a lot of views and really positive
feedback and i've had a lot of requests
from people to do another video where i
saw chess.com puzzles in a very high
rating range and i'm going to set the
same rating range in this video as in
the first of these videos 2700 to
3100 and i'm just going to do
a couple more puzzles at this level and
i'll do my very best as i did in the
first video to explain my thinking
process
obviously when i solve puzzles at this
level i do make mistakes you know my
accuracy is probably around 80 90
percent uh and if i make a mistake i
won't re-record the video we'll turn it
into an instructive moment the point of
this channel is not to make myself look
perfect but to provide maximum
instructive content so i'll do my very
best
to explain these and i'll probably do as
many puzzles as i can fit in about 30
minutes so without further ado let's
solve a couple of puzzles okay
if you haven't watched the first video
go ahead and watch it but you might
remember that if our puzzle really
stumps me i will take uh
sometimes even a minute in silence to
think about it and i'll sort of announce
that if that happens
but just warning everybody that that's
normal and i you know i won't hesitate
to do that
okay so it's white to play
in in this first exercise
and uh
this is interesting so black is about to
promote
their pawn we're up a rook in the night
so this is clearly one of those puzzles
where
you know either we're gonna have to stop
the pawn somehow using checks or we're
gonna have to let black promote and then
fork the queen so we're gonna have to
shoehorn the king onto a particular
square and then use our knight sometimes
or our rook to skewer or fork the king
so
i've seen puzzles like this before
probably you have as well and we're
gonna start by considering some of the
most obvious moves so
let's start by considering the check so
95 check
black can just go king d5 and i don't
even see any checks and i don't see any
forks black promotes knight d8 check is
a little bit more promising so knight d8
check black's king can go in several
different directions but let's assume
that it goes toward the pawn knight d8
king d5
now you can take this pawn with check
okay that's something
the king keeps waltzing toward the pawn
king c4
now we can stop the pawn from behind we
can go rook a5
but then black goes king b3 and even
though we have all these pieces i don't
know if we can stop king b2 and a1 queen
so let's do that again knight d8 check
king b5 rook h5 king b4
knight c6 check
was that the line that we were looking
at knight d8 king b5
oh we were looking at king c4 okay king
c4 rook a5
king b3 now can our knight make it in
time to one of the key squares knight c6
king b2
i don't see it i think black is able to
promote the pawn and force us to give up
a rook 98 i'm skeptical about so that
leaves us with rook h6 check that just
feels like the right first move so rook
h6 check the king has several different
directions if it goes to c7 we can stop
the pawn with rook a6 if it goes to b7
i feel like we've got to be winning
there with some knight check so for exa
for example
if we go knight d8 check
the king has to make contact with the a6
square king a7 then we go knight c6
check
ah but then black can go
oh my goodness there's a beautiful line
there then black can go king a8
and we'll get to that line shortly we'll
return to that line but let's first
consider rook h6 check king b5 because
that's the same strategy that black took
previously which is to go toward the
pawn rook h6 check king b5
okay well it looks like the only serious
move is rook takes h5 check
now the king has to keep going king b4
okay so let's say we stop the pawn with
rook h1 black goes king b3
and i think we make it in time we go
knight e5 king b2 knight d3 check and we
force the king away from b2 then we're
happy to sacrifice the knight and once
we get our rook and put it on a1 so that
line is is is winning for white so
returning to the other line rook h6
check king b7
knight um
knight d6 check
uh knight d6 check
wait a minute we can also go knight d8
check
i already forgot what the initial move
see that's the danger of returning to a
line rook h6 king b7 knight d8 check
yeah it was that king a7
knight c6 check
and now black has to go king
a8 and the move that i see there
oh
no that line doesn't work so let me
think in that position
that's a key position when the king is
on a a rook is on h6 and our knight is
on c6 oh and there we can go knight c6
to a5
black promotes to a queen we give a
check on a6 with the rook the king has
to step to the b to b8 because it can't
go to b7 knight's covering and then we
remove our knight to c6 with a discover
check against the black queen on a1
that's pretty crazy i think that's the
solution i think we can go for rook h6
now i was confused initially 96 check
doesn't come with the same effect
because the king can step backwards to
b8 and the knight covers the rook's uh
transition to a6 we have to give this
check
now we give knight c6 check let me just
verify yes so if black had gone king b7
then we would have given a check on a5
and the knight would have returned to b3
so this is forced
now we go knight a5
again if black goes king a7 here we're
already in time to stop the pawn we go
rook a6 check setting up the discovery
then we have the discover check we take
the queen and obviously we go around and
take the pawn it was a 2948 problem very
difficult exercise because you had to
keep track of all of the possible king
retreats and all of them basically had
different refutations like this one you
had to go back and stop the king with
your knight this one you had to stop the
pawn this way here you had to involve
the knight and stop the pawn that way
and in the main line you needed to let
black promote so fantastic exercise you
know great
for training visualization and tactical
vision deep into a line let's move on
black to play here okay so what do i see
well currently white is up a piece
white's got three minor pieces and white
is two but white's rook is hanging so i
see that white circus hang i see that
there's contact between the bishops so
that's something to keep in mind and the
third thing that i see immediately is
that
in some variations there's a rook h1
check hanging in the air obviously
checking immediately why it has rooked
you on that doesn't do anything but you
know it's good to make make mental notes
to yourself like oh this move is
something i want to not forget about so
we should start by checking queen takes
g4 i don't really understand yet what
what the point of this is oh so queen
takes you for white plays knight takes
g5 and this bishop on e4 covers the uh
covers the h1 square which is which
doesn't allow rook h1 and if we go queen
g1 check then the idea is queen f1
and again we seem to have reached a dead
end their widest two pieces for a rook
which is not particularly good for us
now bishop takes c3 is something we
could start with
oh so we can start with bishop takes e3
let's consider that for a second
um
now
if white recaptures then we take the
rook and we're up in exchange i mean
that has to be winning for black so
after bishop takes e3
i feel like white has to step back with
with the rook so let's say
white goes
i don't know rook rook g2 or rook g1
well if i goes rook g1 so bishop takes
e3 rook g1
there's a move that i have my eye on
which is knight
which is um knight d4 the bishop takes
e3 rook g194
and then if white plays queen takes e3
then there's knight c2 check winning the
queen
so bish should be through rook two one
knight t4 and if white takes on d4
then f2 is hanging we can play bishop
takes f2 check and then we can take the
rook
i feel like that's got to be winning but
here's the thing after oh after bishop
takes e3 white could play rook g2 in
order to keep the f2 pawn protected so
that after knight d4 white can take on
d4 but in that position guess what move
comes to the rescue then we have rook h1
check because the f3 knight is now on d4
that's it's basically made white has to
give up the queen because of the the
first rank check so bishop takes e3 rook
g2 knight t4
and the queen is hanging so white can't
take the bishop with with the pawn
uh i feel like it's got to be bishop
takes e3
now
rook h1 trick we already checked
queen takes g4 we looked at so process
of elimination kind of helps here i feel
like it has to be bishop takes e3 it is
and the response here is f takes e3 that
makes it easy for us but the hard part
was of course calculating rook g2 it's
like i like to compare this uh to this
this thing called iceberg theory i think
developed by hemingway in writing which
is that
you know the actual when you develop
your characters
uh he said i think he said something
like 80 of the character development
doesn't make it into the book right but
in order but that 20 benefits from you
developing the character to the fullest
extent it's the same when you're solving
exercises it's going to be very
frustrating when you've just calculated
an entire line and the server doesn't
give that move but it you haven't wasted
your time it's still part of solving
so and here we're up a full exchange
okay
good stuff let's move on so whoa jeez
black to move lots lots going on the
bishop is hanging
three different pieces can capture it
and it's important not to get
overwhelmed in these in these cases
we'll solve it you know if we can go
step by step and and figure out break
this position down into its component
parts so what do i see well we just we
should just start by considering what
happens if we take the bishop with
various pieces so if we take with the
knight right that just seems like the
most natural move to me
it appears to me that white's only
serious idea is knight g6 check
so knight takes h6 knight g6 check king
h7 ah
i see the point so i see that the queens
are are in a standoff there's a
potential discovery with the rook you
have to notice that initially so knight
takes h6 knight g6 check
king h7 knight takes f8 check and
regardless of what we take the knight
with the rook plays uh the rook right
right plays rook g7 check either
capturing the bishop or just putting it
on that square does it matter and the
queen on e6 is lost because the queen is
undefended so
this is out of the question because of
knight g6 check and if we play knight
takes h6 knight g6 check king g8
uh then white still takes on f8 and i
feel like it's oh wait a second so i see
something there so knight takes h6
knight g6 check king g8 right
knight takes f8 if we take with the rook
then we run into the very same problem
rook takes g7 wins the queen but what if
we take with our king
so boom boom boom boom boom with a king
and if white plays rook f4 check we take
that rook with the knight and we
simultaneously defend the queen and in
that resulting position if i doesn't do
that we've got a big material advantage
as black we have two pieces for the rook
and we have this monster pawn center so
if white just plays rook h4 there then
we trade queens and that end game has to
be winning so preliminarily i feel like
it's got to be knight takes h6 but it's
important in these more complicated
puzzles to check the other moves as well
so queen takes h6 i've already ruled out
because what happens there is white
plays knight g6 check
you have to move your king up to h7
then white white takes the rook on f8
with check and if black recaptures
perhaps you could pause the video and
see if you could figure out why it's
moving your head
so now there's no longer a standoff but
there is a situation where the king and
the queen are on the same file so white
just slides the rook over to h4 and
picks up the queen that way
and that leaves us with bishop takes h6
which i thought was a viable candidate
move but i think it runs into the same
problem that we're familiar with there's
knight g6 check
now king g7 walks right into another
discovery so king age seven is forced
knight takes f8 check
we have to take with the rook because
the bishop is pinned and then again rook
g7 check so i think the only way to
avoid getting into that discover check
is actually to take with the knight
now not taking the bishop isn't an
option because white's threatening this
and this we have to take the bishop i
think we've managed to solve this by
process of elimination let's go with it
so here not king h7 but king g8 and here
not rook takes f8 but king takes f8
and this is a very nice problem it's not
really tactical in the conventional
sense right the solution isn't some sort
of sacrifice it's just a matter of very
patiently identifying the main ideas
and uh you know using process of
elimination which is a legitimate method
of finding
finding uh the bet the best move so
let's move on to an end game these are
usually pretty tough so let me take a
drink of water as i adjust my eyes to
this position
i feel like i get madder now i'm gonna
take a sip of water
and pause the video
just along for the ride it moves knight
at g6 and bishop f4
h6 and in order to resign the game here
so
um
this is this is an end game
and it's quite clear to me that we're
gonna have to promote one of our pawns
so we're gonna have to there's gonna be
some trick where we
kind of promote it and we win the black
circle we skewer it right if you've
solved your share of chess.com puzzles
you kind of can often sense what the
solution is going to look like without
really knowing what the moves are
so we should start probably by examining
the most obvious moves which are h takes
g6 and h6 what happens if we push the h
pawn because the h pawn is the one
that's unrestrained the b pawn
is restrained by the rook
so intuitively i feel like h6 has to be
the move just because it looks right
it's the furthest away from the king so
if we play h takes g6 i i feel like
black plays rook takes b5 and then if we
push g7 black can stop the pawn with the
king black and stop the pawn with the
rook and the king is very close to the
pawn it just doesn't feel like that
works so let's check h6
okay so h6 let's start by
calculating rook takes p5
so rook takes b5
if we keep pushing with h7
ah so i see an idea if we play h7 and
then black stops the pawn from behind we
have a very typical trick there we go
rook c8
threatening to promote black has to take
the pawn and then our rook drops back to
c7
and and skewers the king to the rook so
h6 rook takes b5 h7
ah but black has rook ba black can stop
the pawn from the side rook b8 and then
slide the rook over to h8 and the pawn
is going to be lost
so the next step in such situations is
not to abandon the idea but to try to
modify it i think a lot of people forget
this crucial step you have an idea
clearly this idea has a component to it
that that probably features in the
solution we saw this cool idea with rook
c8 so let's see if we can reshuffle the
move order if we can change things up a
little bit and eliminate the issue so
one idea that comes to mind is h6 rook
takes b5 what if we start with rook c8
what if we take away the eighth rank
from black shurik and then if black
plays rook h5 we again play h7
and we use the same trick that
transposes them to the other line so h6
rook takes b5 rook c8 does black have
any other way of stopping the pawn i
don't think so
right black can't do it with the king
the king is too far away
black can't do it through the seventh
rank because again this king is blocking
the rook's access to the seventh rank
and you also have to make sure that your
opponent can't give you a series of
checks black can black and play rook b3
check but that doesn't help i mean we
can just bring our king back
and anytime black gets to the h file we
we push our h pawn down to h7 and it's
the same the same old trick regardless
of where white's king is
so after h6 let's just make sure that
black doesn't have any other defensive
resources so h6 if black tries to bring
the king over to f7
i feel like we just win by playing b6 it
just intuitively seems to me that these
two passers on the sixth rank have to be
overwhelming
so h6
and if black plays
i don't know rook h4 then we can play b6
rook takes h6
um ah but if we play b7 ooh so now h6 or
k2 we can just play rook takes g6 h6 or
h4 we can just take the pawn on g6 and
with two extra pass spawns
it's gotta be if that's not winning okay
i take my hat off but let's give it a
shot h6 and here's the key moment right
h7 very tempting and once you see an
idea like this it's so tempting just to
make the move but remember to check for
alternate defenses that's how they get
you in some of these more complicated
problems rook c8 now we play h7 we
skewer the rook we win the rook not
terribly difficult but very very nice
end game trick that you can incorporate
in your toolbox okay next problem okay
we're about 20 minutes in so we
definitely have time for a couple more
um white to play this one a lot more
tactical so we're clearly attacking
black's king we're down a piece
currently but we've got a bunch of
attackers here so this is probably going
to be an exercise where you have to find
some sort of a check wait a minute this
is just made in two
they tried to sneak one past me here
didn't they queen c7 king e6 queen d7 is
just checkmate okay
that is nazi and you know what why they
do that i actually kind of like that
that some of these made in two puzzles
are are high rated it's because
you know
it realistically models what happens in
actual chess games where often the
solution is very simple but you over
complicate it right i already started
thinking about bishop g5 what if we open
the e file you know what if we sack this
way or that way and you have to remember
just to check for the simplest possible
solutions right the series of checks
that might lead to checkmate
um so i i actually quite like that that
they have these exercises peppered in
there
but that means we get to do another one
and this one also looks very tactical so
first thing i see is that black's king
is surrounded by white's pieces the
second thing that i see is that black
threatens to infiltrate with queenie one
check so in my mind
i'm kind of telling myself okay
maybe white can allow queenie one check
but then you're gonna have to zigzag
your way out of the checks and that
seems pretty unrealistic given the way
black's pieces are placed because if you
allow queenie one check
and then you allow bishop e4 check i
mean white's king
is gonna get either checkmate there's
just no way that white's going to escape
the checks altogether it's going to be
either perpetual or it's going to be
checkmate so that tells me one of
several things it tells me well it tells
me that white's moves probably have to
be checked and the moment
i said that to myself i noticed the
solution
so
there's two checks in this position that
are
potentially useful one is rook d8 check
the other is queen d8 track and they
both have the same idea
you know let's say queen d a check
rook takes d8 rook takes d8 king h7 it
doesn't matter if there's a rook or a
queen on d this is going to be checkmate
so the question is which one do we give
well and the way we're going to find the
answer is by understanding what happens
if black doesn't take the rook on dave
because after rook d8 check black can
play king h7 and the rook on a x-ray
defends the h8 square so rook h8 is not
checkmate
and if we play rook d8 king h7 queen h6
well that doesn't do anything because
the king just takes the queen
okay well how does queen dhak change
that well it changes it very directly
queen d8 checking h7 and now the rook on
d7 is able to capture on f7 with check
driving the king up to h6 and then the
queen returns to g5 with a very elegant
checkmate so also a pretty easy problem
28 okay so they go with rook takes the
eight now we're okay chase so we got a
series of pretty simple problems let's
hope that we get one over
three thousand
let's see what the next one throws at us
okay black to play
this one at least just glancing at it
for a couple seconds does look quite a
bit more complicated
so let's try to get a handle on what's
going on here well material seems to be
equal both sides have three minor pieces
i don't really care about the palm count
black is up a pawn but that's totally
unimportant so what i'm noticing first
of all is that there's a battery on the
h file so there's the possibility of
delivering a check on h1 we'll have to
consider that move but let's do it a
little bit later let's let's make a
couple more observations first
another thing i'm noticing is that the
knight is frozen to f6 you can't move
the knight because unless it's with
check because of the checkmate
but on that note i mean the knight on e5
is pinned by the bishop so the solution
might involve just going after this
knight and sometimes what the what
they'll do in these more complicated
problems is they'll give you a there
will be a red herring right so you might
think oh this has to be a checkmating
problem because the king is weak and i
could check it not like that rook h1
check but in reality the solution is
just something as simple as winning a
piece right or just going after the
material
and and we'll have to make sure we don't
forget about that so
let's start looking at moves now rook h1
check king e2
i don't see a follow-up okay we can take
the rook on e1 white takes back
i don't understand what we've
accomplished by driving the king to e2
the king actually is probably safer on
e2 than it is on f1
so practicing what i preach let's try to
modify this idea maybe we can make
another move first and then we can give
a check on h1
well there's something i noticed what if
we play bishop takes e5 first
and then only after rook takes e5 then
we go rook h1 check king e2 and we win
the rook on a1
now that resulting position is not that
one-sided we're up a rook there but our
king is still under a pretty big attack
and in that resulting position white can
play a simple move like queen takes d4
and i'm actually not convinced that
black is totally winning there it seems
to me that white's got a pretty
significant attack despite our extra
rook so
we're gonna put this move aside it the
solution might be bishop takes c5 but
let's see if we can find anything more
compelling and if not we'll go for it
okay so another thing we could try to do
is go after this knight we could play
rook takes e5
rook takes e5 seems forced
and then i was thinking of moving the
knight back to d7 but there's a bishop
on b5 that could capture it that's that
seems futile and if we play rookie 5
rookie 5 in their queen h1
that seems to be a much worse version of
the other line because the knight on f6
is going to hang at the end of the line
okay so another idea is to play rook f5
try to chase the queen away from f4 but
that doesn't do anything queen takes d4
and white is totally fine
so other than this bishop takes c5 idea
i don't really see that much else i'm
gonna take about 30 to 45 seconds in
silence and i'm gonna think about this
and then i'm going to share my
conclusions and we're going to go for a
move
and take this opportunity to
take a little water
by the way if anyone from
gerald steiner is watching this video
most people on my stream know that i'm
not a big sponsor guy i like my screen
to be
clean for their only to be a chessboard
but i'll accept to sponsor a sponsorship
from uh
geralt steiner it's my favorite
sparkling water that and logitech
okay
so
let's think
you know i don't see anything other than
bishop takes e5 i think it might be
bishop takes c5
and then rook h1 rook takes a1
and probably black is winning there
probably white's attack is insufficient
let's go for it it is bishop takes c5
very good
and it is check and it is take ooh and
we have to find another move here see
this is going to be a tough one
this is going to be a tough one
so but let's not panic so why is
threatening check made in one white is
threatening queen d6 that we know
how can we defend against it well
we can try to defend the d6 square how
we can play knight back to e8 but then
white can still play queen d6 knight
takes d6 bishop takes d6 beautiful mate
there
so it doesn't seem like we can defend
the square we're gonna have to open up a
square for the king instead now which
square can we open up there's nothing we
can do on the g file right i mean queen
g7 is out of the question can we open up
the e8 square can we intercept this
bishop well actually we can we can play
bishop d7
and then queen d6 check we meet with
king e8 and i actually don't think that
white is a follow-up there bishop takes
d7 knight takes d7 that looks fine
we're threatening to take on b5 with
check
i think it's got to be bishop dc well
nice see that that last one bishop d7 i
actually really like it when these
exercises force you to find one of these
moves because it's tough and it really
makes you think defensively which is a
very important skill that was a great
great exercise and we have time for one
more so let's see if we can end
uh in style here okay
so wow one of these where there's two
rooks against two rooks but our pieces
are
are
obviously much much more active than
whites and again i i've solved a couple
of these types of exercises and
generally
the solution is going to involve some
sort of series of checks where you drive
the king onto a particular square and
then you either skewer the rook on a1 or
you deliver checkmate it's something
like that but let's
let's let's start analyzing moves so the
move i think it's not i don't think it's
rook f5 check because then white plays
king e1 and attacks the rook on d2 and
buys himself time and it doesn't seem
like we can afford to lose tempo
rook f2 check looks more promising work
f2 check
king g okay so if king e1 then white
loses a rook because we go rookie five
check king d1 and then rook f1 check
skewering the rook anyone so rook f2
check forces king g1
and in that position we have to think
because we can play king f3 check but
then the king escapes to h1 and once the
white king reaches h1 i don't actually
think that we have anything
so let me again take a little bit of
time in silence here because i think i
see it but i just need to verify
there there there
i'm pretty sure i see it i just need to
verify the lines
wow this is amazing
oh if this is the solution this is a
super cool move so here's how i approach
this right
if we think logically right we don't
want the white king if white's king
lands on h1 as i said
it's going to be incredibly hard doing
anything to that king because it's
protected by the rook we are never going
to be able to check white on h2 does
that make sense
so the idea occurred to me to prevent
the white king from escaping to the left
how can we do that well we can do that
by moving our king out of the way
but that doesn't seem effective because
that walks right into a check that walks
out right into rook f7 the other way to
try to do that is to play this weird
looking move rook g2 but it's very
logical if you think about it you're
preventing king ju1 now what is black
threatening after rook g2 well black
threatens to play rook up 5 check king
e1 and rukshi one check and skewer the
rook on a1 and it doesn't matter where
the rook on a1 goes if after rook g2
white goes rook d1 then rook f5 check
kingy one rookie one check king d2
and white black wins the rook by playing
rook d5 check there's always going to be
a second skewer if white's king and rook
are stacked so after rook g2
white has to defend against that and the
first defensive move we have to consider
is rook f7 right
but rook f7
allows us to move to the h file
and there we could go rook h2
threatening rook h1 now there's no
longer a way for white to defend the h1
square because if white plays king g1
then we step aside to h3 the king is
forced to move back to f1 and then we
play rook h1 and skewer so rook g2 rook
f7 i think we have rook h2
i think we have rook h2
and if if kingi won by the way then
there's rookie 5 check
now after rook g2 white could also drop
the rook back to h1
but there we can play this very cool
sequence
wait a minute
yeah we can play this really cool
sequence rook
f2 check
if king g1 then king f3 is checkmate
because the h1 square is now blocked
okay so rook g2 rook h1 rook f2 check
king e1
then we play king g2
but not immediately if we play king g2
immediately there's a rook h2 check
dislodging the king and we get a rook
trade and white is out of the woods so
rook g2 sorry rook g2
hook h1
rook f2 check king e1 we have to give
another check on e5
driving the king further so it's not
making contact with black's rook then we
step forward to g2 attacking white
torque on h1 now if white's rook moves
anywhere except e1 then there's a skewer
and a fight truck moves to e1 then we
trade and then we skewer the other rook
with rook f1 check because remember our
king is now on g2
that is i know that's hard to keep track
of so i and i forgot to mention at the
start of the video that it would be a
good idea to have a board handy and
actually set up these positions and
um and follow along as i dictate the
lines especially if you're newer to
chess because i don't expect it to
follow all of this forgot to mention
that i hope you've been doing that uh
you know because that that's a good way
to help yourself not not get overwhelmed
so let's go for that let's go rook g2
that's the solution so they go with rook
f7
now we think that the move is rook h2
king g1 and because of this x-ray you
can step back to h3 forcing the king
back to f1 and then come around take the
rook and our king has an extra square
what an amazing exercise and really an
exercise in logical thinking right in
order to decode this and i think a lot
of people will look at this they'd get
overwhelmed there's a lot of checks it's
hard to
get a grasp on the position we've had a
couple of these in order to get a grasp
on the position you often have to figure
out like what you don't want to allow
generally speaking so the way i solved
this is i i said okay well i don't want
the king to go to h1 i know if it gets
to h1
we're probably not going to have
anything and then you literally ask
yourself is there a way to prevent king
h1
and you consider your options and once
you start considering rook g2 you start
to understand why it's good because you
have this big threat and whichever way
white moves white opens up another
square that you can get your piece to
and that was eight gm level problems i
managed to get them all right they were
not that easy i loved the selection
today i hope you enjoyed the video and i
know these are very challenging videos
to follow but hey i'm just following
what people like uh hope you hope some
of the explanations made sense
and i hope you enjoyed your foray into
grandmaster level problems i'm
definitely gonna make more of these
videos
uh as as we go along thank you so much
for watching hope you enjoyed and i will
see you in the next video
[Music]